après donc tout de suite après donc ce
film le conformisme c'est le dernier
tango à paris
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas engagé jean
louis trintignant pour jouer le rôle
qu'a tenus marlon brando bon évidemment
je voulais du moment que je tombe
amoureux toujours des acteurs de mes
films je voulais faire dernier tango à
paris avec jean louis trintignant et
dominique sanda mairie même dominique
oui bien sûr immédiatement après
dominique était enceinte
donc il pourrait pas tourner et jean
louis trintignant en larmes presque
il m'a dit excuse moi je peux pas me
mettre à poil ton film est très
important que ce soit vraiment comme il
doit comme ça écrit dans le scénario
et moi je suis une sorte de timidité et
c'est alors je les appelle avoir été un
peu partout où je suis allé voir les
deux grandes vedettes du moment qui
était jean paul belmondo et alain delon
belmondo m'a dit je ne fais jamais c'est
un film porno alain delon m'a dit je le
fait que si je puis être le producteur
du film
moi j'ai trouvé c'est un sujet trop
délicat pour avoir à prendre le
producteur et l'acteur qui était la même
personne
alors comme ça j'étais un peu triste là
mais d après tout ces débâcles ses
tentatives
qui n'ont pas marché ces sorties mar
amado qui était quand même un peut-être
a été mieux comme ça mais attendez vous
avez été brouillées commandement d'où
après ce film non il ya eu un moment de
pur séparation disons que j'ai l'airé vu
seulement il ya deux ans donc ça fait
presque 20 ans après we vingt ans après
et oui
non il n'était pas content je ne sais
pas il voulait dédier un peu
désacraliser vous l'aviez jeu c'est
peut-être le marron c'est quelqu'un qui
a un incroyable sens de l'appareil va
c'est alors ça m'arrive assez
et pourtant il savait très bien que ce
qu'on faisait
je lui ai dit écoute je sais que je vais
faire c'est à lâcher de ton visage
le masque barlan brennetot actes au
studio je veux marlon brando le maroc
avec lequel je dîne tous les soirs
presque privé
ouais bon je crois d'être réussie de
cette histoire lui quand il a vu le film
je crois il s'est senti un peu violée
dans ce sens dans le sens de la vérité
qui l'aurait jamais voulu montrer au
public
bon c'est passé quelques temps et après
22 ans se retrouve il ya deux ans j'ai
l'appel je lui dis bon je suis à los
angeles un bon millésime pour quoi on
peut pas se voir j'avais envie de le
voir lui même bien sûr on peut se voir
et 10 km maintenant tout de suite
alors je suis monté sur ma voiture je
conduis sur mall road and drive pour
arriver chez lui il habite toujours dans
le même endroit comme il ya début des
années 70 moi j'avais peur d'avoir un
accident j'étais tellement émules
tellement touchée par cette invitation
mais alors ce film est un scandale quel
scandale c'était en 1972
qu'est ce qu'on a c'est vrai parce que
c'est un film il faut dire qu'un film
est assez terrible dont le sucre les
deux sujets c'est le sexe et la mort
c'est bon mais en même temps il ya cette
fameuse scène du
2 du beurre qui a acquis qui veut
vraiment et est ce que vous avez fait de
la provocation l'a acceptée est-ce
qu'elle était vraiment indispensable
je sais pas si c'est la scène qui fait
rappeler le film peut-être je crois
qu'elle est c'est là le scandale était
la violence du film
moi j'aime bien de rappeler au public
français qui sait pas qui en italie le
film a été condamné à être brûlé comme
une sorcière dans le feu comme ça pour
détruire tout cas pellicule et moi j'ai
été condamné à deux mois de prison avec
ses suspensions conditionnelle et puis
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais été
déchu de vos droits civiques
oui c'est ça je me suis rendu compte
après que je pourrai pas voter
ai je demandé mais pourquoi
le monde mais parce que vous avez
télécom dame n'est pas obscénités et
vous avez perdu vos doigts cellectis a
été un peu dur c'est pas ça et c'était
un moment vraiment j'ai vu j'ai envie de
lui les partis au vu des résultats est
positive
vous avez l'impression d'être une sorte
de pestiférés en italie ou pas
d'un côté la condamne la condamnation à
la prison il ya aussi un plaisir de
martyrs
bazot ligne oui incertaine
il ya quelque chose de fascinant de
l'autre côté le fait de pas être capable
de voter aux élections là c'était l'
humiliation complète le vatican bien
entendu et des comptes ça va de soi mais
mais est ce que vos amis communistes
avait il réagi à l'époque très bien sûr
seule la solidarité et de la paix des
chocs et d'un film comme ça en france
aurait choqué quand même dans le parti
en france le film n'a pas été touché du
tout c'est tex avery non mais
[Musique]